what would happen to you if a black hole
the size of a coin suddenly appeared
near you short answer you die long
answer it depends is it a black hole
with a mass of a coin or is it as wide
as a coin suppose a u.s. nickel with a
mass of about 5 grams magically
collapsed into a black hole this black
hole would have a radius of 10 to the
power of minus 30 meters by comparison a
hydrogen atom is about 10 to the power
of minus 11 meters so the black hole
compared to an atom is as small as an
atom compared to the Sun unimaginably
small and a small black hole would also
have an unimaginably short life time to
decay by Hawking radiation it would
radiate away what little mass it has in
10 to the power of minus 23 seconds it's
5 grams of mass will be converted to 450
tera joules of energy which will lead to
an explosion roughly 3 times bigger than
the atomic bombs dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki combined in this case you
die you also lose the coin if the black
hole had the diameter of a common coin
then it would be considerably more
massive in fact a black hole with the
diameter of a nickle would be slightly
more massive than the earth it would
have a surface gravity a billion billion
times greater than our planet currently
does its tidal forces on you will be so
strong that they'd rip your individual
cells apart the black hole would consume
you before you even realized what's
happening although the laws of gravity
are still the same the phenomenon of
gravity that you'd experience would be
very different around such dense objects
the range of the gravitational
attraction extends over the entire
observable universe with gravity getting
weaker the farther away you are from
something on earth right now your head
and your toes are approximately the same
distance from the centre of our planet
but if you stood on a nickel size black
hole your feet would be hundreds of
times closer to the center and the
gravitational force would be tens of
thousands of times as large as the force
on your head and rip you into a billion
pieces but the black hole wouldn't stop
with just you the black hole is now a
dominant gravitational piece of the
earth moon
Cole of death system you might think
that the black hole would sink towards
the center of the planet and consume it
from the inside out
in fact the earth also moves up onto the
black hole and begins to Bob around as
if it were orbiting the black hole or
while having sways of mass eaten with
each pass which is much more creepy as
the earth is eaten up from the inside it
collapses into a scattered disc of hot
rock surrounding the black hole in a
tight orbit the black hole slowly
doubles its mass by the time it's done
feeding the moon's orbit is now highly
elliptical the effects on the solar
system are awesome in the biblical sense
of Awesome which means terrifying tidal
forces from the black hole would
probably disrupt the near-earth
asteroids maybe even parts of the
asteroid belt sending rocks careening
through the solar system bombardment and
impacts may become commonplace for the
next few million years the planets are
slightly perturbed but stay
approximately in the same orbit the
black hole we used to call Earth will
now continue on orbiting the Sun in the
Earth's place in this case you will said
I this bonus video was made possible by
your contributions on patreon thank you
so much for your support the topic is
based on the question on the ask science
subreddit and the glorious answer by
Matt Kaplan who also worked with us on
this video check out his blog of quarks
and coffee for more awesome stuff like
this if you want to discuss the video we
have our own subreddit now to learn more
about black holes or equally interesting
neutron stars click here
you